la colère n'est pas retombée à
minneapolis
après la mort de john terry wright un
jeune afro-américain battu ce dimanche
par la police lors d'un contrôle la
ville a connu une deuxième soirée de
rentrer population et forces de l'ordre
un nouveau drame qui passe mal auprès
des habitants nous manifestons
pacifiquement nous n'allons pas
continuer à accepter que la police tue
des noirs sans raison sans contrôle
routier sans problème de santé mentale
donc c'est juste la façon que nous avons
appris à être solidaires et à montrer
que nous sommes debout pour une cause
cela continue à se produire
il est accablant de devoir se réveiller
de voir qu'un jeune homme noir a été
assassiné par les forces de l'ordre
j'ai 25 ans cet homme avait 20 ans dont
terry wright avait 20 ans il aurait pu
être mon petit frère pour éviter tout
débordement supplémentaires minneapolis
a instauré un couvre feu dès 19h mais
des dizaines de manifestants étaient
toujours présents lundi soir face au
commissariat de brookings center la
ville voisine où a eu lieu l'événement
tragique
les forces de l'ordre ont de leur côté
communiquer par le biais du chef de la
police locale
jugeant cette mort accidentelle selon ce
dernier la jante responsable de la mort
de dante et wright aurait confondu son
arme à feu avec son taser
son nom n'a pas été rendu public
contrairement à l'enregistrement vidéo
du drame une affaire qui a poussé joe
biden à prendre la parole
je n'ai pas appelé la famille de john
terry wright mais mes prières se tourner
vers eux ce qu'il s'est passé vraiment
tragique mais je pense qu'il faut
attendre de voir ce que nous dira
l'enquète l'intégralité de l'enquète
nous savons que la colère la douleur la
souffrance qui existe chez les personnes
noires pour ce contexte est réelle
sérieuse et importante mais cela ne
justifie pas la violence ni les pillages
à la suite de ce drame le sport a
également été mis à l'arrêt dans la
ville la nba la ligue majeure de
baseball et la ligue nationale de hockey
ont décidé de reporter les rencontres
prévues tout en présentant leurs
condoléances
enfin la mère de dompter wright a pris
la parole pour demander un retour au
calme reste à savoir si elle sera
entendue